you know we have our core values and the
number one value and by far the most
important is
is patience first and it's really about
the patience
[Music]
david golan thank you so much for
joining me on 20 minute leaders
thanks for having me well you know
artificial intelligence
healthcare helping save lives a post-doc
at stanford
this is a complete honor of mine so i'm
very very glad to have you
david you're the cto of this ai i can't
believe you just tell me
you're over a hundred people across the
us and israel
and that's just insane david right
before we go
back to your personal journey give me a
little bit of context
what is this ai and how do you integrate
artificial intelligence with healthcare
yeah so our mission at vsai is
to facilitate better care for patients
by applying artificial intelligence
detecting
for example stroke or other pathologies
that require
immediate attention and alerting
the right physician immediately using
our ai and using a mobile platform so
they can treat the patient much faster
so just you know for context about the
problem you know you're saying this idea
of detecting
strokes you know when i think of
somebody having a stroke i think about
the movies i'm thinking about somebody
who's stopping in the middle of the
street
they're starting to realize that
something is weird they maybe fall down
and then eventually somebody will call
9-1-1
i'm guessing that the problem is that
oftentimes it's too late right i mean
that every second there counts
yeah so stroke is the single most time
critical condition in all of medicine
with the exception of you know a kid
choking on a grape
every minute that goes by a patient
loses two
two million neurons that translate to
over four days of disability free life
so it's really a race against time and
you know we all have these these images
from for media of someone
having a stroke and being rushed to the
hospital the
sad fact is that the delays typically
happen within the hospital system
so the largest delays are after the
patient is admitted
actually more often than not even after
the patient is
imaged so the patient was in a city
scanner
somewhere you know in a file system
there's a sequence of
bits and bytes that tells this patient
is having a stroke
but just the system it's a human-based
very sequential linear system is not
efficient at triaging those patients
identifying
who needs emergent care and who doesn't
and sort of skipping the queue and
making sure the right patient gets the
right
uh the right treatment so this is
basically what we do
right so it's not a problem of
proficiency of taking care of it but
it's a problem of diagnosing
the urgency of the situation right
exactly
exactly so it's it's really not about
you know the in the context of ai and
radiology and interpreting
scans and you know people also saying
hey i will replace the radiologist that
will not replace the audiologist who's
better
it's really not about being better it's
about being everywhere
24 7 being diligent never taking a break
which computers can do and humans can't
not to mention the cost
right so the ai is always there in the
cloud every single scan goes to the
cloud we're
at about i think 45 000 scans a month
now wow going to the cloud being
interpreted about one out of ten
is a stroke oh man the ai identifies the
stroke
sends an alert the physician gets the
physician by the way
is more often than not in a different
hospital or at home or driving or
whatnot
they get the alert they have a mobile
platform they they can view the scans
they can communicate with the team
and this really changes the flow of
healthcare from this
sequential one stop after the other you
know
very slow process yeah something you
know everybody gets the alert everybody
sort of sinks in on the mobile platform
makes a decision
go go go and we treat the patient much
much much faster
so it just paint me the picture again
where is the scan taking place
how am so let's say i am the one who is
experiencing the health condition
where am i physically located while the
scan is taking place and
and why am i so disconnected from the
from the whole uh
health care system that you're talking
about yeah so
if if you're unfortunate enough to have
a to have a stroke or to be suspected of
a stroke
you will be taken to a hospital right to
an er
and you will be scammed okay between 60
and 70
of the time the facility that you're
being scanned at
does not have the full capability to
treat you as a stroke patient
you will need to be triaged and
transferred to another facility
it's called a comprehensive stroke
center right and
i mean immediately you know
if you've been in the hospital once you
sort of know how inefficient this can be
immediately you see there's a chain of
handoffs that needs to happen
and remember also you're in the smaller
hospital right it's less experienced
they don't see as many strokes so
they're right practiced with them
and and this is what you know due to
human error due to overload due to a
tired physician or just due to like
random stuff like someone calling
someone else while they're already on
the phone with a third party
right there's delays introduced and
those drops drops in this process
so we we completely eliminate this and
you know actually
if if you're okay with this i just want
to share
something from literally from from
earlier today yeah
of course on linkedin uh i can send this
after what the post on linkedin
um from piedmont we just went live with
piedmont
it's an exciting day for us at piedmont
we have officially launched with ai
across our health system
our first case came through and lvo
alert lvl is the type of stroke
was received even before the images made
it to the system
physician notes that this saved us at
least 15 minutes on this case
15 minutes is 60 days of disability free
life
and saves 150 days of potential loss of
functional independence
right this is from today this is like i
shared a tale david
i'm i'm getting no i'm getting emotional
here and listening to you say that
how so so you're reading this post and
i'm literally tearing up as i'm as
i'm hearing this because this is
probably something that i'm the most
passionate about using technology
to to literally save lives you know a
lot of entrepreneurs go and
and build products that are trying to
make the world a better place or have a
positive impact you're literally
saving people's lives and you're not
just saving them from life enough you're
you're also saving their well-being it's
not just about whether they survive but
it's about their quality of life moving
forward
which i think is completely inspiring
talk to me a little bit about your
personal journey
going into this so uh so you know you're
teaching me attendant television
university you're
an algorith you're you're working
algorithms at vmware you're at postdoc
at stanford how do you go into this
realm of artificial intelligence and
transition into
co-founding this amazing company yeah
so i mean it's a good question and you
know sort of my
background has been a bit random uh i've
throughout my adult life have been sort
of gravitating towards what's
interesting and fun
and challenging and as you mentioned i i
worked in i developed algorithms in the
tech industry i did some
uh cool stuff in in my undergrad and
master's and
phd and it came to stanford for a
postdoc to focus on statistical learning
and genetics and genomics and you know
solve the world's problems and like
i guess two two main things happened one
of them
is you know i guess everything depends
on luck but
i came to stanford exactly when
the first time for the first time uh um
a conversion neural network class was
taught at stanford
and i was like completely randomly i
stumbled upon it and i said
well let's let's go and listen what is
this stuff that
you know sort of keeps coming up
recently everybody's saying this is a
big deal
um and i go there one or two
uh you know lectures and it's obvious
that this is a game changer it's
obviously
something really really big is happening
here it's not
you know another method another
algorithm it's really something that's
going to change a lot of things do you
remember who was teaching the class back
then
yeah yeah it was andre andre kilpathy's
famous
cs 231a like everybody
everybody's done cs231n it's a the
notorious class of convolutional neural
networks
yes so i mean that was the first time it
was taught at stanford
and it was absolutely mind-blowing wow
um
so i mean immediately i started to think
okay let's see how we can apply that
uh in research in genetics and genomics
and started you know dabbling with
medical imaging
so playing with with all sort of stuff
um
completely unrelated to that uh i
actually
you know the story i told you about the
patient uh being scanned and so on i
actually
actually experienced it i was admitted
about five years ago to stanford
hospital with a suspected stroke
which he actually yeah so actually it
ended up not being a stroke and
just a different neurological thing
that's completely reversible and i'm
fine and healthy so
no don't worry um but like everything i
tell you about the delays
about the disconnects i literally
experienced those
being like unable to speak paralyzed in
half of my body on a bed
at stanford looking around saying what
the hell is going on why are things
taking so long
um and and it is in one of the best
hospitals in the world so whatever
exactly it's like right it was like
monday morning you wouldn't say like
christmas eve or something
it was absolutely absolutely um
mind-blowing so you know half of the
brain is like super freaked out that i'm
going to be
you know disabled for the rest of my
life and half of the brain is like
what the [__] is going on um
um and i was fortunate to meet my
co-founder
uh chris mansi uh i was introduced
actually following this
this incident by a mutual friend chris
is a neurosurgeon by training
wow and he was in the business school at
stanford and we
actually met other friends you know
sitting in his backyard
on the bonfire um and i sort of told him
my story and he looks at me like
dude you're lucky you're alive
everything is
fine i lost like dozens
of patients on my operating table over
stupid stuff
like someone not picking up the phone at
the right time and i actually came to
stanford
to fix this wow and like
how would you fix this like if
everything was automatic
if you know computers were there instead
of humans things would have been much
better
and i remember we actually googled on
his phone like some images
and i looked and said you know i think
you know deep learning we can probably
automate this
unbelievable when was this
how beginning of 2016.
wow so we're talking about four years
ago and
fast forward um and you're running over
a hundred person company
and you're already and you're saving
lives so talk to me a little bit about
about
about what's happening today so you're
you say you have 45 000 scans a month
10 of those are are showcases which
means
that as that in the current state you're
literally helping save
the lives of 4 500 people either saving
them from life and death or saving their
well-being for hundreds of days right
yeah yeah so i mean now we will fortune
we've seen uh very rapid adoption in the
u.s we're live in over 500 hospitals
seeing a lot of patients um there's you
know accumulating
evidence that implementation of this
software
you know reduces the time improves
patient outcome reduces length of stay
in the hospital
and all that coming from different
hospital systems across the u.s
so it's fairly robust um yeah
it's really exciting we're launching new
products we're expanding beyond stroke
we have a brain bleed product we have a
few others that are sort of
coming down the pipeline and it's uh
yeah it's actually been
so david i i have to ask company culture
uh because it's something that's
fascinating for me you know as a
as a young entrepreneur myself and
thinking about leadership and what it
what it means to really motivate people
and
and i'm seeing my class at stanford and
my friends from 8200
it's all about mission-driven companies
right we want to join companies that are
mission driven that have a purpose that
we know that we
feel a part of a community do i'm
i'm assuming this but if you're looking
at the hundred plus people that are
working at this ai
is there a shared goal here do people
understand
the magnitude of what you're achieving
here
oh i i think the answer is is yes like
we
put a lot of effort into it and it's
super important first of all we have you
know we have our core values and the
number one value and by far the most
important is
is patience first and it's really about
the patients
um even recognizing that it's about the
patients not about it not even about the
users
or paying paying for the product
um we have different backgrounds in the
company
people coming from healthcare which is a
lot of the commercial slash customer
facing
they get it immediately we have you know
a customer success team
many of them are stroke nurses and
stroke coordinators
who sort of jump chip because they
understand that this is the way to
really transform
in israel we have the engineering team
and you know we're slightly removed
from what's going on so we do a lot we
have
uh you know in all hands we have what we
call the magic moment section
where we share two one or two
you know stories like the one i shared
with you earlier
um we have our brain time session we
call it we have
it's a 30 minute every week where we
just review interesting cases
what happened did they use the app did
they use it properly wow
something strange happened um so
yeah so we really try to connect uh
even you know ev every single person in
the company
to the fact because i mean this is what
differentiates from obviously
this as as you know place of work you
can go work in other places
some may even pay you more money um
but i strongly believe it's it's
one of the only places where you can see
a very you know direct line from your
work
to numbers of lives saved unbelievable
so talk to me a little bit about this
intersection of our artificial
intelligence and and healthcare
and medicine in general where is this
headed because this is something that
you know
i guess 15 10 15 years ago there wasn't
too much innovation going on with
especially using these technologies
and and completely transforming the way
that healthcare is processed and just
like
you know the amazing things that you're
doing there's other companies like like
zebra medical vision that are they're
doing phenomenal things
and and other companies around the world
what is the trend and
how can people that are perhaps pursuing
you know
a phd in artificial intelligence or that
are mathematicians
how can they find this this smooth
integration
and implementing these algorithms into
actual sustainable products that can
actually improve people's lives
yeah well i mean that's i guess that's
the million dollar question
um and i think there's few ways to
attack first of all in terms of the
trends
um yes for a very long time not a lot
has happened
and again i think most of the the reason
is
that people focused on trying to make uh
trying to beat humans at their own game
like reading better there was a lot of
focus in oncology for example in breast
mammography
um trying to be better than a human in a
very hard task
what we did at viz which was which was a
first
and it was a a new regulation created by
the fda for us
was not to compete with humans in their
own game but say
where do we have where does the computer
have the advantage
well time is of the essence right right
so actually algorithms are not more
accurate than humans
humans like the expert treating this
head scan
they don't miss a stroke it's not about
accuracy
it's about getting them in front of the
right patient at the right time right
and there you can show very very
substantial clinical benefit
we convinced the fda they created a new
regulation called computer-aided triage
for this and now i just actually recent
recently we did a survey there's
about 30 devices in this category using
us as a predicate and this has become
the number one way for ai companies
to to have like you know a foot in the
door in the healthcare system
so but what what is like what is the
the lesson i don't think the lesson is
you should go do triage um
i think the main thing is that you have
to sort of forget about ai and we have
ai in our name here
but let's forget about the ai for a
second and you have to really find a
problem that needs fixing a pain point
that's so painful
to patients to physicians and also to
you know to the
financial people at the hospital right
because stroke is
you know financially a very big deal
it's actually the number one health care
expense in in the uh um
so you and then you say what do i need
to fix it and ai
may be part of the solution and by the
way when i think of viz
when when we ask our customers what is
like the biggest feature of this that
you like the most
ai doesn't always come up first they
it's part of the whole solution the
solution is
a technology a mobile viewer um a
chat a skill chat they can use it's ai
it's also a customer success
representative that really understands
stroke
and works with them to improve their
stroke workflow and how
they leverage what viz has to offer to
improve their own workflow and so on
so it's really holistic it's so
what i'm trying to say is if you're an
ai practitioner
and you um you have a hammer and you're
now looking for a nail
like everything looks like a nail don't
do that first
find a problem uh convince yourself that
there's a clinical case a business case
and then if ai can help you know
wonderful 100
and it's inspiring because it's what i'm
gathering from this is
and you're saying it's not the ai that
is viz
it's viz ai is a component it's it's a
tale of vis and
and you're providing this holistic
experience that is that is trying to
capture a lot of the misalignment
within the within the industry or within
the the the process of a potential
stroke patient
they all the ai is is sort of the helper
tool to allow that to happen but it's
all these other resources whether it's
the customer success person
or the secure chat or understanding the
the problems of that specific
organization
and i think that's a pr that's a really
big lesson that i'm taking from this
because as a technology enthusiast
myself
i'm constantly reminding myself that
it's not just about the algorithm it's
not just about the code it's about
how do you actually bring this to market
and make it something that's useful
david this was inspiring and insightful
thank you for taking the time to do this
i'm sure that it's you know running over
100 company and doing the things that
you're doing a
this is a i'm definitely very very uh
very honored that that you're willing to
do this
but before we leave i have to ask for
three words that you would use to
describe yourself
so um okay so the first one i think it's
two words but they still haven't been
the same it's i would say
naive slash optimistic like
like people make fun of me into this all
the time that i always think some
things are like would be really easy to
do um
and they always turn out to be harder
but you have to sort of believe that you
can't do it and that it's possible so
take the first step
um and i think the second one would be
you know some something you know big for
me right now is being a father
yeah i'm a father of three and we had uh
we have a six month baby that was born
just before the lockdown here um
so you know kids have been a big thing
but recently even even more than that
and the third thing i would say um
i mean i thought about like going with
like a gig nerd thingy but i actually
went with a statistician
uh i'm i'm a hardcore statistician by
training
not the machine i mean do machine
learning and stuff but like my training
is in statistics
and i consider myself a statistician who
thinks with
applied statistics to how he thinks
about the world and that actually has
been extremely useful uh at this journey
and in life uh in general so
yeah i guess i guess we'll go do those
three david thank you very much
keep helping save people's lives and
i'll keep following the journey thank
you very much
thank you take care